we begin this half hour in perfect
harmony songs for kids is an
organization that brings music to
children battling serious illnesses they
perform for kids in hospitals in an
effort to give them the strength to
fight on we traveled to Atlanta to meet
the man behind the music - Josh Rifkind
music is a powerful prescription for
healing from the first moment of
knocking on a door and when they watch
their kid smile and start to rock it's
like a life preserver being thrown out
[Music]
believing he could make a difference
Rifkin launched songs for kids back in
2013 with a road trip and we traveled
the whole year around the country
performing at nearly every Children's
Hospital in the United States the one
thing about our job is it promotes very
direct human connection immediately it
was something that like I chose to do
songs for kids first connected with
Anderson Krieger by handing him a guitar
battling cancer for seven years music
helped him cope with months of
hospitalizations they could give me all
the medicine they wanted take my blood
but I could do this if I wanted to do
this you controlled the music yeah
[Music]
from bedside sessions Rifkin builds
bonds that can help lead these patients
away from the darkness of their disease
they'll finally get up with us and then
they won't leave stage they literally
will not leave their have to go to like
a treatment or therapy but they're like
I'm singing a few more songs earlier
this year
Rifkin opened the songs for kids Center
in Atlanta a safe space where kids
facing serious conditions can take music
lessons or write a song expressing what
they're going through
it's been a lifeline for 13-year old
Marines we go physical abuse as an
infant damaged her spinal cord
she's already endured 19 surgeries we've
seen our daughter miss out on so many
things while she's engaged in her battle
well josh is somebody who's a hero
because he's going back for kids who
would have otherwise gotten left behind
[Music]
what's it like to work with Josh I'll
enter the door and he's like what's
happening guys it's just so refreshing
because you can like definitely be
yourself around him Rifkin has found his
calling a decade ago he was managing
professional musicians but felt
unfulfilled the son of a surgeon he grew
up idolizing his dad so he found a way
to combine the two things he loved most
music and medicine I love the fact that
regular people can make an impact these
days Rifkin's famous friends often stop
by when they're in town in August the
Backstreet Boys
let us sing along
I definitely love love ruining the
Backstreet Boys it's pretty good yes
really good songs for kids has touched
thousands of lives supported primarily
through private donations
they've never charged for anything what
is that moment like when you see a kid
light up you just get chills all the
time it's so moving and you would think
after 13 years oh I've seen that right
so I am numb to the experience it is
like a new experience all the time
energy it's amazing and I Marie who was
in that piece I watched her light up so
shy and then you saw her performing her
song and it really is amazing do not
underestimate the ability of this group
they obviously need money so if you like
the story go help them I know we're not
talked about things like that but do
great cause